Від кав’ярні "Незалежність" до іграшок та футболок з "бавовнятком".
Як підприємці-переселенці попри повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в Україну
та окупацію не опускають руки і "з нуля" починають бізнес у нових містах?
Допомоги нам не треба ніякої. Ми самі. Зараз у держави і так своїх проблем вище даху.
Нам не треба.
Сергій та Лариса переїхали до Києва з села Григорівка Запорізької області
після семи місяців окупації.
Подружжя мало два продуктові магазини у своєму і сусідньому селі.
Будували власний бізнес сім років, часто працюючи без жодного вихідного.
Та в один момент втратили все.
З 24 лютого, коли почалося масове вторгнення, якраз там магазин в Тарасівці
- сполучення Токмак-Пологи, йде траса. І тією трасою почали йти колони.
І там по шляху багато магазинів - їх усіх вони розбили, знищили, виривали БТРами двері.
Вони все повигрібали. І порозбивали всі вітрини, поламали прилавки,
поламали стелажі. Потоптали ногами, порвали одежу.
Інший магазин вцілів, але працював лише тоді, коли було що продавати.
Так Сергій і Лариса працювали до так званого референдуму.
Це була остання крапля. Тому що ми як підприємці, ми працювали
на українських документах, тобто по українському законодавству.
А для того, щоб працювати там, якщо вони проводять референдум,
то треба російську ліцензію, це раз. По-друге, для того, щоб її отримати, треба паспорт.
А ми не згодні з цим, категорично ні. То не паспорт. Навіщо нам та ліцензія?
У Києві діти підштовхнули батьків знову почати власний бізнес, незважаючи на труднощі.
Перше, що важко було, це морально було важко.
Наважитися морально щось робити, взагалі щось. Вже коли ми взяли оренду,
підписали договір - тоді вже якось пішло. Наново треба було шукати бази, оптові бази,
моніторити ціни. Тому що за цей період, коли постійно працюєш,
то ти ж за цінами слідкуєш, а коли ми стільки місяців були в окупації і відвикли.
Там взагалі ціни шалені. І коли той рубль ввели - це взагалі катастрофа була.
І хоч магазинчик працює лише місяць, та Сергій із Ларисою вже мають постійних клієнтів.
Люди, які втратили свій бізнес, найголовніше - щоб не втрачали надії.
Це все відбудуємо, все відновимо. Головне, щоб не втратили надію і людяність.
Ми також чекаємо, коли додому, коли визволять. Ми оце, якщо налаштуємо це все,
ми залишимо діям. Або повантажимо все і додому поїдемо. Ми не знаємо,
як там визволятимуть, чи там залишиться щось, чи не залишиться.
Микита і Тетяна - переселенці з Херсона. Там пара мала чотири кав’ярні
і планувала відкрити п’яту.
Нашу кав’ярню обстріляли з "Градів". А ще під час окупації одну кав’ярню взламали,
але не змогли винести.
Через вторгнення Росії замість розвитку кавового бізнесу їм довелося два місяці жити в окупації.
Було дуже складно з продукцією, було дуже складно з кавою, зі стаканами.
Я їздив по місту, Таня працювала на одній кав’ярні, я їздив по місту, шукав,
де знайти каву, де знайти стакани. Молоко ми взагалі замовляли з-під корови.
О 16-ій місто вимирало, тому що знали, що як тільки заходить сонце,
то військові починають творити все, що завгодно.
Коли почалися чутки про референдум - Микита і Таня вирішили все залишити
і будь-що виїхати з окупованого міста. Адже працювати на Росію вони не хотіли.
Вони казали, що якщо буде референдум в Херсоні, буде Херсон Росією,
і тоді будуть мобілізувати чоловіків, хлопців.
Також були ще такі чутки, що буде Росія - значить треба буде бізнес свій
переробляти на Росію. А ми це ніяк не хотіли робити, тому ми вирішили виїхати.
Щоб вирватися з окупації, херсонці подолали 62 ворожі блокпости,
а дорога зайняла 3 доби. Спочатку Микита і Тетяна планували запустити бізнес в Одесі,
але потім вирішили переїхати до Києва. Тут вони відкрили кав’ярню "Незалежність".
Для нас це символічна назва, не просто так назва.
Проживши в окупації два місяці, ми зрозуміли ціну тієї незалежності
і хотіли передати щось таке цінне для нас.
На новому місті підприємці все почали "з нуля": шукали приміщення,
самостійно робили ремонт, меблі, налагоджувати зв’язки з постачальниками і клієнтами.
Ремонт самі, все самі. Нікого не наймали, стіни пошпаклювали,
пофарбували, що не треба було - зруйнували, винесли, вивезли.
І почали фарбувати, пиляти меблі, все збирати. Поки я пиляю -
Таня знаходить десь кондитера. Поки я фарбую - Таня знаходить, де каву купувати.
Люди допомогли зібрати на генератор, щоб кав’ярня працювала під час
вимкнення електроенергії. А от від держави підприємці допомоги не чекають.
Ми вирішили самі себе підтримувати і, в першу чергу, підтримувати нашу державу,
а не нас. Ми платимо податки і донатимо на ЗСУ.
Тому що зараз наша треба підтримка нашій державі.
А от у Ксенії із сім’єю у рідному Сєвєродонецьку не залишилося нічого.
Жінка мала свій танцювальний клуб, який від початку повномасштабного вторгнення
перетворився на укриття. А за вікном - було видно, як розриваються снаряди.
Тому сім’я поїхала до родичів у Берегове на Закарпатті.
15 березня ми сім’єю разом з нашими домашніми улюбленцями,
це 4 кішечки, виїхали з міста Сєвєродонецьк. Більше речей у нас із собою не було.
Але треба було за щось жити і їсти, тому Ксенія згадала про своє давнє захоплення.
Я згадала, що я у свій час дуже багато в’язала речей, іграшок на замовлення.
І поспілкувавшись і обговоривши це питання всією сім’єю, ми ризикнули
і я почала в'язати перші іграшки. Це були зайченята-сплюшечки.
Їх замовляли не лише в Україні, а й закордоном - у Німеччині, Польщі
та Великобританії. Та розвивати бізнес під час війни - дуже важко, каже жінка.
Із самого початку, коли починали ми свій бізнес, по-перше, були проблеми
з поставками матеріалів. Також вимикання світла дає свої від’ємні результати,
тому що не завжди є можливість працювати.
А коли почалася програма для підтримки жінок з Донбасу, Ксенія подалася і виграла грант.
На ці кошти жінка придбала обладнання для розвитку виробництва.
Тому що я вирішила паралельно розвивати не тільки виробництво іграшок,
а ще й виготовлення шоперів та спортивних рюкзачків.
На сьогоднішній день ми вже почали розробляти моделі шоперів та принти,
а також у нас з’явилися вже в продажу футболки.
Це патріотичні футболки з "бавовнятком", принт яких розробила моя донька.
У передноворічні свята ми вирішили сім’єю зробити лімітовану новорічну колекцію іграшок.
Разом з тим Ксенія відкрила у Береговому ще й новий танцювальний клуб
та оформилася як підприємниця. І хоч, каже, найскладніше було починати все "з нуля"
у чужому місті, та жінка ніколи не думала про виїзд закордон.
Питання про виїзд закордон ми навіть не ставили.
По-перше, тому що я вважаю, що наша Україна - це, окрім територій,
це ще й наші люди. І зараз, як ніколи, всі люди повинні підтримувати нашу Україну
всім, чим можна. У кожного свій фронт. Тому навіть тут знаходячись
і роблячи свою невеличку справу, я вважаю, що ми допомагаємо Україні.
Також ми частково прибуток направляємо на донати для підтримки
нашої потужної, найсильнішої армії - ЗСУ.